hi I'm thank you so much for coming how
do I know Beth Neville has flown in now
a couple times in a month from Guatemala
right in the last month and so we're we
are thrilled oh yeah thanks for coming
in between yeah yeah jet said fun I'm
really thrilled to be here yeah I did
want to ask is slightly shifting gears a
little bit about what when I was looking
at the website I was shocked to see that
the illiteracy rates in initiative san
mateo i guess are around seventy percent
and that this is much higher than the
rest of guatemala and I guess I was
wondering and the community came to you
and asked about building a high school
what is the role of activism in in this
kind of situation is it may be the role
of the government to provide a high
school and I'm not sure if the if you've
thought about or if the community has
already tried to put pressure on the
government to to do this yeah I don't
know how they would put if they've put
pressure and they've actually gotten
received they call it receiving high
school the last President did start this
just hasn't been the governmental policy
to build middle schools or high schools
anywhere and they were very few of them
now they're I fate they said they've put
them in every municipality the last
president but that being said they suck
they're horrible the ones that the
government schools are just awful and I
don't know if that's because of the sort
of culture of oh it's government he not
a sort of government work stereotype
culture so we we actually had it we
started a middle school and high school
and there was an offer from the
government the Ministry of Education
saying will we're offering a middle
school so we hand it over our school for
years so that we wouldn't have to pay
salaries you know maybe they would build
a building and and it just in one year
just went toppling down I mean is the
quality
assistant nobody call a cyst NC a-- the
the the rate at which kids and teachers
would show up to class road what is that
colony we attended a tennis yeah thank
you and it just went way down her
there's so much so that the parents came
to us and said please please we initiate
your school and we're willing to pay
because they have to pay it's not a
public school our school they pay that
eight ten twelve dollars a month but we
also try to keep it public in the sense
that we don't turn people away if they
don't have enough money we have
scholarships so I don't know it's a bad
costs about 10 times that much to
educate them but active there's the
community is very active between a lot
of things like right now they're really
against the electric companies trying to
put in a big hydroelectric power station
private company and they're really
really mean they're actually taking up
arms against the engineers so kind of a
lot of activism there do you not for
lack of activism didn't I think but I
think it's just hard going a little town
going against the whole big ministry of
education bureaucracy which is pretty
significant do you follow what baby well
I was just just curious um you know in
these various organizations I guess
through education maybe is that a way
that larger structural change can come
about that people are educated and then
themselves maybe go into government or
into policy it's our hope okay yeah
there's one little kid and I just saw my
way he's not I don't mean he's little
he's just just graduated last year and
he's going to study law and he's
interested in politics he's interested
in local politics and he'll he's such a
positive guy I think he'll be great so
yes that's a whole point is that they'll
do whatever it takes who knows what that
will be